[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICOLE FORSGREN: Today we are
going to be talking about,
if you don't know
where you're going,
it doesn't matter how
fast you get there.
And when I go speak with
companies, and organizations,
and developers, and
operators, and executives,
we want to start doing
everything better, and faster,
and stronger, and more
secure, and more reliable.
Who's heard this
about a million times?
Yes.
OK.
Who are the devs in the house?
Who are the ops in the house?
Who's management and executives?
Yeah.
We all want to do
the thing, right?
Because who wants to be awesome?
All of us.
Who wants to suck at things?
OK, good.
Trick question.
I was like, who's just
raising their hands
because this is the exercise?
We want to do everything
better because--
we got into this because
tech is exciting and fun,
and we get to make
things, and be creative,
and watch the lights light
up, and do Hello World,
and make things awesome.
But it's tough when
we aren't necessarily
sure what that means.
Except also, sometimes that's
great, because we understand,
and we're the experts, and
we know what that looks like.
So how is it that we do this?
So that's what we get
to talk about today.
Where are we going?
How do we actually
improve performance?
And how tricky is that word?
Performance is a tough one.
How do we make it a carrot
and not just a stick?
How should we measure it?
Why should we actually care?
And then at the end, what
is this culture thing?
And how do we
actually measure it
so that we can then
make it better?
So let's start with,
where are we going?
Who here's heard
of maturity models?
Do we know what
maturity models are?
I'm so excited.
Who's not heard of
maturity models?
Do we want a real quick recap?
Do we want a recap anyway?
OK.
So maturity models are
this wonderful thing
that help explain where we
are, and they're usually
like predefined levels.
By the way, they're
usually made up
by someone trying to
sell us something.
They all go to level five.
Do we know why they got to
level five, most of them
go to level five?
Because we all
have five fingers.
It's true.
Who here has played
"World of Warcraft?"
Fine.
Who here has a friend who's
played "World of Warcraft?"
Yes.
Here we go.
When "World of Warcraft" first
came out, this was the land.
So even if you haven' tread,
even if all your friends have
played, we all get this.
It's a map.
When it first came out,
it went to level 60.
You could create a
bunch of characters.
Clearly, I've played
"World of Warcraft."
Clearly, I had to stop
playing "World of Warcraft"
because I had to finish
work, and school, and jobs,
and stuff.
You could be a mage or
all this cool stuff.
It went to level 60.
You could have a bunch of tools.
You could have a
bunch of technologies.
So let's create ourselves
a maturity model.
How do we feel about this?
Let's pretend we're executives.
Let's create a maturity model.
How do we feel about this?
Yay.
Y'all are my people.
This is great.
But we don't have
very much time,
so our maturity models are only
going to go to level three.
So the first level is
going to be level good.
And we're going to like
conquer land on the left.
The second maturity model
is going to be level--
and we'll go to level 40.
The second level is
going to be level great,
and it'll be all of
the land on the left,
and half the land on the right.
And we'll go to level 50.
The third level will be
called level amazing,
and we will conquer
all of the lands.
Sound good?
Yay.
OK.
So we progress.
We all move forward.
We've conquered all the lands.
And at the end of this
exercise, what happens?
We get a gold star
on our forehead.
Everyone, gold star
Participate.
Gold star on our forehead.
We collect our fat bonus check,
and we pay our consultants.
Congratulations.
Now let's fast
forward several years.
And what happens?
This is now the land
of "World of Warcraft."
The land has changed.
The landscape has changed.
By the way, you can
now go to level 110.
The technology has changed.
The competition has changed.
Y'all, you can have pets now.
Does anyone care that we got
our gold star on our forehead
and we got to level 60?
If we go out and try to
fight, what's going to happen?
We're going to get
our butts kicked.
Our competition has changed.
Our customers'
expectations have changed.
And this is a fun,
silly example and story,
but it's also very
relevant for technology.
So the challenge
with maturity models,
particularly as we talk about
developing and delivering
technology and
features for customers,
whether they're internal end
users or external end users,
is that it doesn't help us
actually address what matters.
They tell us that we're
done when we reach
a pre-defined destination.
And the whole rest of the world
keeps addressing and answering
what matters and
what's important.
They also tell us and leaders
to stop dedicating resources
once we've arrived.
By the way, resources
aren't just money.
It's time.
It's attention.
It's education.
It's training.
It's paying attention to what
our customers need and want.
They also tell us that we all
follow the exact same path
to success.
Remember our super fun
made up maturity model?
It said that we had
to explore that land
in the exact same order.
Now if we think about this
in terms of technology
transformation, getting
our teams better, faster
delivering--
think about the organizations
that we're in right now.
Think about all the teams that
are working on and delivering
technology.
Do they all look the same?
Probably not.
So their next step forward--
will it look exactly the same?
Probably not.
And the next step.
Again, probably not.
So how do we expect
a step by step
by step map and
prescriptive path
to make sense for something
that's so complex?
Now, maturity models tell us
that technology is a checklist
to just be completed.
And when we're done,
we're done, and we
move on to something else.
But we got into this
game because it's fun,
and it's exciting, and we get
to keep discovering what's new.
Now listen, I
fundamentally understand
why maturity models are good,
and why they're comforting.
It's because it lets me
get that someone else has
been where I've been, and that
they know what comes next.
But if they point me
too far into the future,
that's not helpful.
Thanks, Nicole.
You just brought down the room.
Sad trombone.
So how do we actually get there?
What's helpful?
What's helpful is to
focus on a constraint.
By constraint, I basically just
mean, what's holding me back?
What's the hurdle for each team?
Focus on that, fix it,
execute well and completely.
I make it sound simple.
It's not.
I know it's a challenge.
But that's also why we
rely on our expertise,
and on our experts, and
also on our community.
One thing I really really
love about the DevOps movement
that I've seen over
the last decade
is that we really rely on
each other to move forward.
OK, so then where are we going?
A direction is helpful.
I didn't say we
have to fly blind.
We should know at least what
direction we should be facing.
OK, so then what
direction is that?
And the number one
question I get so often
is, is there one
metric that matters?
Can anyone guess the
right answer here?
No.
Sorry.
Go ahead and tell
your executives that.
No, there's not.
But if I have to pick
something, this would be it.
It would be software
delivery performance.
And it's not one metric,
but it is four of them.
And they tend to
hang out together.
They all go drink tea
together, and they
have a little knitting
circle, and they chill,
and they throw darts.
Here's what I mean when I say
software delivery performance.
I mean some throughput
and stability measures.
Throughput is speed.
So I'm talking about
deployment frequency--
how often you push code.
I'm also talking about
lead time for changes--
CodeCommit to code
running and production.
And then I'm talking
about stability.
Stability is time to restore
service and change fail rate.
Now, someone challenged
me earlier this week,
and I really appreciate
her doing that.
Because she said, why
are you only focusing
on things that are
easy to measure?
Now really quickly, I'd say
these aren't necessarily easy.
But she had a really
fantastic point.
Because there are so many
things that are important,
and why are you
focusing on this?
I'm not focusing on
this at the exclusion
of other things, like culture,
and people, and quality.
But this is important
for a few things.
First of all, this
focuses on the performance
of software delivery.
And notice that I'm measuring
things that are intention.
So often people have
told us that we can't
have both speed and stability.
Has anyone heard that, for
things to be stable or safe,
we have to slow down?
We've heard this.
It's been whispered
in dark alleys.
We've found over five
years of research
and 30,000 data points,
these actually move together.
And when I say move
together, I mean
I take all these data
points-- do we want
a stats tangent really quick?
Can I [INAUDIBLE] for a second?
OK.
Yes, OK.
I take all the data points,
and I throw them in the hopper.
A very technical term--
throw it in the hopper.
And I do a cluster
analysis, which
means I want to see how
they cluster together.
So I see them all
grouped together
in statistically meaningful
ways, and then a gap.
So they're statistically
different from another group.
And then a group, and then
a gap, and then a group.
I'm real creative,
so I call them
high performers, and medium
performers, and low performers.
But what that means, when
they group together, I'm
seeing the speed and stability
measures move together.
The high performers are
doing everything well.
The medium performers--
we're seeing the middle group
hang out together.
And some people are
on the struggle bus
together down at the bottom.
We see movement together.
There aren't trade offs.
I think that's important.
So if you walk away with only
one thing, have it be that.
Speed and stability
are possible together.
So then what's next?
Some people wonder
where they might fall.
This is my eye chart.
Sorry it's so small.
This comes from
the 2018 Accelerate
State of DevOps report.
So when we take this very
data driven approach,
where do people fall?
We see elite performers.
So this is the highest group.
The high performers can
push code on demand.
Lead time for changes--
again CodeCommit to code
writing and production--
less than an hour.
It's getting it all the
way through your pipeline.
Time to restore service--
again, less than an hour.
Do you know what makes me
super excited about that?
That means that when
you have an emergency--
something breaks-- your regular
process looks very, very much
like your emergency process.
You're not skipping tests.
Everything goes through.
Change fail rate-- it's
between 0% and 15%.
And by the way,
historically, that actually
looks very close to
the 2%, 3%, 5% mark.
Compare that to
our low performers.
These are median numbers.
So we do have a range here.
We see deploy frequency between
once a week and once a month,
lead time for changes between
one month and six months, time
to restore service between
one week and one month.
This is where we're
seeing a difference.
And then our change fail
rate is between 46% and 60%.
Now, if you take a
look at this, you
think about where
your team might fall.
If you don't see
yourself on this chart,
don't be discouraged.
So often I'll get people
contacting me and they'll say,
but I'm not here.
This isn't my industry.
It doesn't apply.
First of all, all
industries are represented.
Highly regulated fields
show up in elite performers.
Crazy cowboy startups-- low
performers were everywhere.
But don't be discouraged.
Because everyone can
achieve high performance.
We just need to start working.
And everyone can do it.
We can all work
together and get there.
But how?
How do we get there?
One does not just walk
into high performance.
So how do we get there?
DevOps, or whatever
you want to call
it-- technology transformation,
whatever your leadership
team likes, just do your
little find and replace.
The cross-functional
community dedicated
to building, evolving, and
operating secure, resilient
systems at scale.
It can include so many job
titles, tasks, and roles.
But I think the part
that's important
is that we work together.
We automate.
We reduce toil.
And we deliver value for
whoever our end users are.
So this is a summary of my
research over the last five
years.
And right now,
everyone is like, what?
Girl.
So let's think of it this way.
We have a cultural aspect.
We have a tooling and
automation aspect.
And we have some process.
It really breaks down
into these things.
We can manage this.
Do we feel OK?
Have we heard
culture is important?
We can do culture.
We're at a tech conference.
Tell me that we've heard
that tooling is important.
OK, we're good here.
And process.
OK, now we're back.
Here's what we see.
So technical practices and
continuous delivery-- that's
at the bottom.
We're going to break this down.
By the way, anytime
you see an arrow,
this is a predictive
relationship.
Lean management and lean
product development--
these are going to
be some processes.
This arrow-- see this SDO
performance-- that's our speed,
and stability, and availability.
So all of these lead
into this stuff.
A quick tangent in the
middle-- outsourcing is bad.
Who's surprised?
Cloud infrastructure helps.
That's a huge driver,
if you do it right.
The things I love
about culture--
we can see, autonomy
helps drive culture.
Western organizational
culture, we'll talk about.
It drives job satisfaction.
Look down here at the bottom.
Identity, if we
really love our work.
Smart investments.
Decreased burnout.
Decreased deployment pain.
Decreased rework.
In SRE land, we call this toil.
We're decreasing toil.
And it helps us with
organizational performance.
And at the very, very
back, at the very far left,
we see transformational
leadership.
Has anyone here had a really,
really great leader, manager,
mentor, or even just a really
dope team lead that somehow
made your work amazing, and you
were somehow kicking out way
more work than you
ever did before?
Yeah.
So this makes sense.
Because their influence
flows through, and magnifies,
and amplifies all the work.
So it looks crazy.
But it all does boil down
to culture, and tooling,
and process.
And we've got some
great evidence
to help us point to
what to look for.
Now again though,
sometimes people
will look at this and they're
like, where do I even start?
This is 37 things.
Let's think back.
Identify your constraint.
What's your team's
biggest hurdle?
Focus there.
Start there.
Eliminate that constraint.
So in theory of
constraints, we call
that elevating the constraint.
Once it's no longer the
thing that's in your way,
focus on the next constraint.
Now, the next big
question I get is,
how do I measure performance?
The biggest mistakes I
often see are these--
focusing on outputs
versus outcomes,
the difference between
individual and local measures
versus team and global measures.
So let's look through
some examples here.
Lines of code-- this
is the best example
I have for outputs
versus outcomes.
It's funny, because sometimes
I bring this up as an example.
And so often people are
like, lines of code?
Who still gets asked
about lines of code?
I get asked about lines of
code at least every month,
almost every other week.
So lines of code is dumb.
And here's the best examples.
Sometimes people are like,
well, more lines of code
is going to be good.
More lines of code is not good.
Who already knows this?
We already know.
Y'all are my people.
This is a smart room.
More code just gives
us more to maintain.
Bloated software,
slows things down,
higher maintenance costs,
higher cost of change.
Maybe less is better.
But who has seen this ridiculous
thing where someone comes up
with this amazingly
clever one line of code
that, two weeks later, no one
can read, no one can interpret,
we have no idea what happened?
Sometimes the best answer
is to delete code, or change
a business process so
that you delete code.
Lines of code just is not
a great proxy for things.
It's difficult.
That's an output.
It's a measure of output.
But it doesn't tell us
what we accomplished.
By the way, that's why we
focus on software delivery
performance.
Because it's at the end.
So let's talk about
velocity then.
So for some background,
when we were in Agile land,
we break problems
down into stories,
which then we assign points,
and we estimate effort
to complete these.
We're all familiar
with this, right?
OK, great.
At the end of the
sprint, the total points
are signed off by the customer.
This is velocity.
By the way, velocity is
a capacity finding tool.
We shouldn't be using this
to measure productivity.
Over the years,
teams have often used
this to measure productivity.
But it's not great as a
measure of productivity.
And here's why.
Velocity is a relative measure.
It's not an absolute measure.
It's relative to the
team, to the tasks
they're doing, to the context
that they're working in.
We should never be comparing
teams on their velocity.
We can also game it by
inflating estimates,
which is understandable.
We want to make sure
that we have our targets.
This last point is the
most important though.
We want to be, again,
thinking about outcomes.
What's the goal?
What are the team's working on?
If I'm working on
a team, and I have
points that I want
to accomplish,
and you're working on a
team, and you have something
that you want to
accomplish, what
happens if there's
something that
needs to be accomplished for
the entire organization that
requires us working together?
I'm not going to help you.
I got points I got to finish.
So we want to be thinking
about outcomes, not outputs.
Finally, utilization.
Utilization is good, but
only up and to a point.
Because more isn't
necessarily better.
It doesn't allow for slack.
And we all know that we
always have unplanned work.
And if anything, when people
come back to me and they
debate this point, I'll
just point back to math.
Queue theory tells me that as
utilization approaches 100%,
lead times approach infinity.
Once we get higher
and higher and higher
levels of utilization,
your teams
take longer to get work done.
I can think about this myself.
The longer my to do
list gets, the longer it
takes me to get anything done.
Why should we care
about any of this?
Why do we care?
Why do we care about
delivering software faster?
Why do we care about it
being faster and more stable?
Here's why.
Teams that deliver
more often-- when
I compare those elite performers
and those low performers,
we see 46 times
more frequent code
deployments, over 2,500 times
faster from commit to deploy,
seven times lower change fail
rate, and over 2,600 times
faster time to recover
from incidents.
It lets us get our features
to customers faster.
It lets us recover
from downtime.
It lets us patch faster.
We can get out our compliance
and regulatory changes
better and faster.
It also makes it just easier
and safer to push our code.
It lets us get back to the fun
part of what it is that we do.
It also helps us contribute
to the organization,
whether that means money,
commercial goals, productivity,
profitability, market share,
or non-commercial goals.
Because we care about more
than just the bottom line.
We care about things like
effectiveness, efficiency,
and customer satisfaction.
And I really love
the shift that we've
been seeing in the
broader industry
over the last several
years to things
like corporate social
responsibility.
And we know that
delivering software better
helps us achieve these goals.
For bonus points, we also
see that elite performers--
the highest performers see
50% higher market cap growth
over the previous three years.
Now with a little
asterisk, that analysis
was only available
for those companies
that are publicly traded on
the New York Stock Exchange.
Now why else do we care?
This also contributes
to quality.
We see high performers are
able to do more new work.
Now, what do I mean by new work?
They don't have to do as much
rework or unplanned work.
We get to do more novel
work, more fun development.
Now, when I see development,
I don't just mean developers.
I was a sysadmin for years.
Sometimes I want to
create new infrastructure.
I want to do more
creating of whatever it
is that I'm building.
That's new work as well.
I don't want to have to
keep fixing stuff that I've
done before.
This was the part that
matters so much to me.
It also helps us
make our work better.
It contributes to
happier people.
Because we don't just want
to burn out all the time.
The thing I love is that
the promise of DevOps
makes work better.
It decreases burnout.
And by the way, burnout
isn't just being tired.
Burnout is when we
don't love what we used
to love anymore about our work.
Making smart investments
in tech and process
actually combats this.
It also helps
decrease deploy pain.
That's that panic when
you push into prod,
and you're like,
please just work.
You know that awful
meme that's hilarious,
but it's funny
because it's true,
with the girl in
the burning house?
It worked fine in DevOps.
Problem now.
It helps get rid of that.
Also, it gives us
better job satisfaction.
And when I say job satisfaction,
our research into job
satisfaction wasn't
just, I like my work.
It's, my work makes good use
of my skills and abilities.
And I have the tools
I need to do my job.
So it's like, I get
to do dope stuff.
We also see higher Net
Promoter score from employees.
So they love what
they do, and they
tell everyone else about it.
And a better
organizational culture.
Speaking of-- I keep
saying "our culture".
Who here has a definition
of our culture?
Who here has three
definitions of our culture?
Who here is sick of
raising their hand?
We always talk about
organizational culture
when we talk about DevOps.
And I think it's
because, for years, we
were doing this
technology thing,
and promising it would
make a difference.
And to be frank, it never did.
And when I started
doing this research,
people told me I was crazy.
I actually almost got kicked
out of my PhD program.
Because for 40 years,
we had research
showing that investments in
technology didn't matter.
Have we all heard this whole--
IT is a cost center?
That sucks.
But here's why.
It was because we used to
just buy tech, and then
walk away, and expect the
magical fairy to show up.
The problem is that if
anyone else could just
buy tech and walk away
and do nothing else,
that doesn't make you
magically better than all
of your competitors.
It doesn't help you make things
awesome for your customer
or your end user.
What we have to do is,
we have to find ways
to differentiate ourselves.
And that requires
technology, and process,
and culture, and people.
And then the magical
fairy shows up.
And so culture is
really, really important.
Because that's
what allows people
who are fundamentally different
and diverse in background,
and technology, and skill set
to talk together and make these
incredibly complex,
diverse distributed systems
work in these ways that
we've never seen before.
And so when we started
doing this work,
we reached back into some
of the other literature
and found this great
research by a sociologist
named Ron Westrum.
Now, he was doing research
into high risk complex systems,
where if something breaks,
real bad things happen.
So I'm talking health care,
nuclear power, aviation.
Notice that there, when bad
things happen, people die,
immediately.
Now to be fair, that's
also kind of true in tech.
Because we're also
working in systems
that power health care, and
aviation, and these very, very
high risk systems.
I remember pushing into
prod, and we almost
had to evacuate an ICU
when a backup failed,
and it failed horribly.
So we've also had these
situations happen,
where something bad happens
and our stomachs knot.
So this organizational
culture maps up
to so much of what
we see when we
talk about having a culture
that values information
flow, and transparency,
and learning from failure,
and bridging across silos.
And so when we
found this, we were
like, this might be a great
way to talk about, and measure,
and think about
a DevOps culture.
Is this resonating?
OK, so let's look about
the pathological one--
power oriented.
It's typified by
low cooperation.
We shoot the messenger.
We don't want to hear bad news.
Responsibilities are shirked.
Bridging is discouraged.
Failure scapegoating,
novelties crushed.
Who here has a friend
that works here?
OK, a couple of friends here.
Across our research, we've
seen about 25%-30% fall here.
And it's highly correlated
with low performers.
Bureaucratic is
very rule oriented.
Now to be fair, this isn't
necessarily a bad thing.
Bureaucratic cultures are
meant to optimize for fairness.
Modest cooperation among these
very, very different teams--
messengers are neglected.
If someone brings me bad news,
I just kind of ignore it.
I don't want to hear it.
Narrowly defined
responsibilities.
Bridging is tolerated.
Failure leads to justice.
Novelty leads to problems.
Who here has a friend
who works here?
OK.
We've got some hands.
I want to say about 55%
of respondents in here,
and it's highly correlated
with medium of performance.
Bridging-- when we
bridge across teams--
so Dev bridges to Ops
bridges to testing,
or even bridges to something
like marketing-- the question
is, what do I mean by bridging?
Now, the final one--
generative or performance
oriented culture.
High cooperation.
High cooperation among
teams that are traditionally
very different.
Messengers are trained.
So what do I mean by this?
I want people to
bring me bad news,
because then when I know
it, then I can fix it.
Risks are shared.
Bridging is encouraged.
Failure leads to inquiry.
When I read that, I think
of blameless postmortems.
And the novelty is implemented.
Who here has a friend,
or is lucky enough
to work somewhere like this?
Who here has no friends?
I love this, because
it mirrors some
of the research done by
Google's teams a few years ago
from project Aristotle.
The background to
some of this research
was, they were wondering what
would make the perfect team.
And if I recall
correctly, I want
to say the hypothesis
moving into this
was that, the perfect team would
have the perfect mix of skills,
like technical skills.
What they found instead was
that the number one driver
was psychological safety.
They feel safe to take risks
and be vulnerable in front
of each other, followed by
dependability, structure
and clarity, meaning and impact.
It comes down to team dynamics.
It comes down to the culture.
That's what really
drives impacts in teams.
And I think it's
particularly interesting,
because as I refer
back to Westrum's
organizational culture, the
thing that was particularly
interesting is, in addition
to defining and predicting
outcomes, it also
helped explain what
happens when things go wrong.
How often do systems fail?
All the time.
Because we're working with
highly, highly complex systems.
So what else we
see is that failure
in these complex systems
will always happen.
There's no way to guarantee
against all failure.
So in these systems we
often see that human error
is the starting point.
And so when we do
blameless postmortems,
we want to understand
where to move forward.
So how can we get people
better information?
And then how can we detect
and limit failure modes?
How can we build
our systems better?
I love this picture
on this example.
Ryn Daniels was at
Etsy for a while.
Is anyone familiar
with this story?
This story is dope.
So at Etsy, they
actually reward people
for finding fantastic
failures in the system.
And why is this?
It's because you have
uncovered an opportunity
to build more resiliency
into the system.
So Ryn here was awarded
the three-armed sweater.
Are we familiar with Etsy?
Etsy is a marketplace
where users
can sell their handmade goods.
One of their users knitted
them a three-armed sweater.
And so every year, they
have an award show.
And Ryn writes about
this on a blog.
And it's on failure
and resilience.
And it really is an honor.
And it's very unintentional,
but the better
you can bring down
the system, it
uncovers fantastic
opportunities for them.
And so this is where we're
Ryn wins and is awarded
the three-armed sweater.
And Kripa Krishnan talks about
this at Cloud Operations.
For DiRT Operations-- so DiRT
is disaster resilience testing.
For DiRT style events
to be successful,
an organization first needs
to accept system and process
failures as a means of learning.
Remember back how failure
was an opportunity to learn?
We design tests that
require engineers
from several groups who might
not normally work together
to interact with each other.
That way, should a real large
scale disaster ever strike,
these people will already have
strong working relationships.
I love that as well--
bridging across teams,
breaking down silos.
So in conclusion, direction
matters more than maturity.
I know everyone loves
to benchmark themselves
against where they are, and
know what level we're on.
But we always need to
keep getting better.
What happens if we
get to level five,
and a few years later, suddenly
the industry has magically
decided that we get
to a level eight?
We just need to keep moving
forward and getting better.
Second, we can have it all, or
at least speed and stability.
DevOps culture and practices
have a measurable impact
on performance,
quality, and culture.
And culture can be
measured and changed.
One more plug-- if any of
this research or information
was interesting to
you at all, the data
collection for the 2019
State of DevOps report
is open right now, and
will be open until May 3rd.